giro político inesperado en Barcelona la
segunda ciudad de españa pasará a estar
gobernada por el partido socialista de
Cataluña el hasta ahora vicealcalde
yauma coiboni será el nuevo alcalde de
la ciudad
condalera conciencia prometo por mi
conciencia y honor cumplir fielmente las
obligaciones del cargo de alcalde de
Barcelona con lealtad al rey y respetar
y hacer respetar la Constitución el
estatuto de autonomía de Cataluña y la
carta municipal de Barcelona
y la carta municipal de Barcelona el
bastón de mando lo recibe como segundo
candidato más votado gobernará Gracias
al apoyo de los comunes de la anterior
alcaldesa a la izquierdista Ada colau
que irá a la oposición y del derechista
partido Popular Dos partidos
antagonistas a nivel nacional el ganador
de las elecciones el independentista de
derechas y exalcalde entre 2011 y 2015
xavietrías fue muy crítico con la
maniobra
van a intentar de todas las maneras
hacer lo mismo que han hecho hoy que es
un juego de magia quitándole la alcaldía
al que se la merecía
la alcaldía
sus once concejales se iban a sumar a
los cinco de los independentistas de
izquierdas republicana para gobernar en
minoría para trias el nuevo pacto Busca
dejar fuera la independentismo tornan
vuelven a hacer lo mismo con las mismas
excusas no quieren un alcalde
independentista dentista Ada colao sin
embargo defendió su legado y atacó la
herencia del gobierno de trias en la
ciudad
supuso barra libre para la especulación
para el turismo masificado menos
inversión en transporte público y olvido
de los barrios populares popular el
partido socialista se lleva una pequeña
Victoria a un mes de las elecciones
generales las consecuencias políticas
con el independentismo Catalán a nivel
nacional aún son impredecibles